the bathroom fight the sequence itself
is supposed to take four days first day
I was thinking oh this is going to be a
hard four days it ended up being four
weeks we kept on going back and
readjusting stuff and then going back
again and readjusting more stuff you had
to get it right if I got it one step
wrong I had to then pause halfway
through and hold him where he was so it
doesn't end up being 40 minute to two
hour reset none of us admitted how how
much it hurts so we are still filming
little pieces of it all the way to the
end of the movie and Henry and I we
looked at each other said this really
hurts doesn't it and he said yeah yeah
I'm so glad you said that all of us none
of us walked away from that scene going
we were all limping not one of us would
ever admit we'd always be asking each
other hey is everyone okay you're right
after that stunt and yet that would look
like a hard fall and and it looked like
you caught something there everyone was
like no no totally fine you know it kind
of you know you'd walk off the set like
yeah yeah there was nothing like your
trailer fizzy you're like oh my God
please